that's awesome to have you in I feel
like your work really needs no
introduction I grew up a huge fan of
your films and I know I'm not alone in
that
but this film that you're here for in
particular seems to be a bit of a
passion project for you it's called
blaze it is the true life story of a
sort of legendary musician please fully
which I had never heard of well most
people have you bad the word legendary
is weird because it's a secret legend
yeah he's a legend in country-western
lore for crazed aficionado you know you
have to be you have to be deeply versed
in Townes Van Zandt before you get to
blissful you know it kind of goes Willy
Merle Waylon Kristofferson guy Clark
Townes Van Zandt and then the secret I
call him the snuffleupagus of the outlaw
country western music scene you know
because you have to really geek out
before you hear place Foley yeah that
whole chain of command there I'd have to
go several years some several layers
deeper so when when did you first hear
of him what was your introduction my
introduction was through John Prine John
Prine had covered clay pigeons and if
you're big Lucinda Williams fan which is
kind of go with me for a second I I said
to my friend who happens to be the lead
of this movie but this is 10-15 years
ago I said hey man John Prine just
released I think maybe my favorite song
he's ever written clay pigeons and Ben
was like no that's plays Foley I'm like
whose plays Foley he's like you remember
um car wheels in a gravel road which is
Lucinda's out and the song drunken angel
is about place Foley I'm like oh yeah he
was shot and killed and I was like oh
and then I sort of put he wrote if I
could only fly that Willie Nelson had
done he wrote Election Day is that why I
love it had done so I he was kind of
this mysterious element and as the
internet started exploding and more and
more music was available what used to be
very hard to find place full of music
became easy
and Ben and I started sharing stories
and sharing tracks that we would
discover so was this something that you
and Ben deke who's so incredible in this
role and this is his first film yeah so
did you guys talk about this for a
really long time because he seems like
such a random discovery of pure talent
yeah well he you know as his father says
to say he's an overnight success it just
took forty nine forty years I mean he is
a beautiful musician and I was a fan of
his music he was in a band in Philly
called the blood feathers and they were
amazing and but they struggled and over
the years of being his friend
I realized just I had a front-row seat
to how difficult the music business is
and when the blood feathers were
breaking up and Ben would tell you he
was powerfully sad you know and he's a
big guy and when he's sitting on your
couch and he's sad you feel it you know
and I was telling them to remember plays
Foley you know there's so many artists
out there in the world that are working
at a really high level that they're
contributing but they're not finding
away in the commercial marketplace but
there's no avenue for them to make money
and that's shame on the marketplace not
on them you know and you got to keep
believing yourself and he picked up my
guitar and he started playing clay
pigeons and that was 2015 into 16 it was
New Year's Eve
we were both it was late at night and I
said you should play plays Foley in a
movie and the more I thought about it
the more I sat on that aisle I couldn't
sleep
it was like an electric shock went
through me and I was like this would be
a great idea because it would allow me
to do something that I thought about
first of all casting him as a musician
as a musician is a very good idea I mean
Lady Sings the Blues Diana Ross that an
amazing Christopherson has done a Willie
Nelson has done just the huge you know
Bette Midler I mean you know there's
lots of great musician actors it's just
David Bowie it's a slight turn the dial
and I knew that Ben
could deliver a major performance and
that he has something to say about
Blaise you know behind you there's a
picture of Charlie Sexton is playing
Townes Van Zandt and Charlie has
something to say about Townsend's music
it's not a posture or a pose he spent
his life playing music he knew Townes
so it was an exciting idea to say to
these musicians hey let's go down the
rabbit hole and really try to do a
serious performance it's funny the
phrase sort of down the rabbit hole the
way this film is structured is very
fluid and really a journey that you take
with these characters through time and
location and not necessarily linear in
any way it's very I know you've written
books it's almost novelistic in the way
it transmits their time as part of you
know you co-wrote the script you
directed it how did you decide on the
structure you wanted to tell this story
you know from the first time I thought
about it as a movie it even before I met
Sybil I you know had this idea where Ben
could play plays and I there was
something if you listen online there's
that's thing called the outhouse tapes
which is we dramatize it in the movie so
right at the end of so a month before he
was shot blaze played this concert he
took all the money he had and he just
recorded it on a little four track and
he tried to play as many songs as they
would let him play it so they exist
somewhere I think he had a fear that
something bad was gonna happen to him
and his weight I just lost my train of
thought what did you just ask me the
narrative oh the near-destruction
exactly well let's see the zcy I lost so
much I thought it's because I often do
it's the way my brain works I would
listen to these tapes and I would listen
to the people talking in the background
and people playing pool and spilling
beer and I kept thinking what is he
thinking about and I kept imagining
songs as a kind of time portal you know
the way that you could listen let's say
for example you're 10 years old and you
listen to hey dude and it means
something you just love it and you sing
along you love it
but you don't really think about what
the words mean or anything and then you
fall in love and you're 21 and you share
with your lover and you listen to hate
Jude every night before bed and you'd
see your guys song and you love it in a
different way and it means something
else then you break up and you can't
listen to it all anymore and then 10
years go by and you turn it back on
again and it moves you and makes you
happy again and all this time the song
has been the same and it was I even kind
of wrote about this a little bit and
before sunset I've always had this kind
of idea you know whether it's Mozart or
Hank Williams that they just did they
were moving through time and I find it
really powerful and I thought wow would
it be cool to make a musical where the
songs just moved through time and then I
read Sybil's book it says she wrote a
book it's blazes one of the great loves
of his life and and she wrote a book
called living in the woods in a tree and
about their time in love and where he
really learned to play the guitar where
he really pushed his songwriting forward
in this treehouse and in in the memoir
she is the same relationship to time
that I do a part of her part of the book
is an older woman talking to a ghost
talking to the real man
talking to herself as a young person she
it just you know it flows like a
waterfall through time and I I knew that
we would have a great time making this
because it was exactly the movie I
wanted to make so you have this shared
way of your train of thought going in
different directions obviously this is
such a personal story for her yeah what
was your creative endeavor like to do it
together she saw the movie as an
opportunity to put this man she loves
his music his music got squashed you
know shot and killed in the street and
his music never got hurt and she really
believes in him
you know she saw the movie as an
opportunity to push the music forward
and she's an artist so she wasn't
confused that I never wanted to make a
docudrama I never wanted to
reenact a Wikipedia page I wanted to
make a piece of art about human
creativity about love and self-sabotage
and friendship and healing and death
right and I want to make a piece of art
about that and use blazes life and his
music as a kind of meditative place to
rest all this you know and she got that
I explained it right off the bat so and
she didn't have to do and she was like
okay that sounds like a cool idea and
the more we got into it the more it was
clear that blaze the man he liked art he
would want us to do that more than
nobody can reenact him right well in it
so true when you make these kind of
films it's not your job to be a
journalist no it's a ballad different
job and we live in an amazing time where
you can see this movie and then you can
google him and then it can take you to
the real music it can take you to Ben's
music you would live an amazing time but
the point of Raging Bull is not to
reenact Jake LaMotta slide they're
making of unbelievable movie but you you
it's what Jake LaMotta means to Scorsese
what he means to DeNiro and you feel
their blood and their sweat all over it
- not just Jake LaMotta you feel all the
people who worked honestly well you just
gave me quite the end with Raging Bull
because you have another fantastic movie
this year first or foster Paul Schrader
yes which I know he wrote Raging Bull
and the driver taxi drivers incredible
American Gigolo I'd sleeper just a few
they're fine they're fine
if we change okay and he made this other
movie that's fine this year that has
like it okay performance from this guy
it's like maybe one of your best
performances I think and was so blown
away by the the depths you guys go to
without really beating it over the head
I don't feel when you do a performance
like that and it actually went to side
trying that question because I'm curious
about something else was your dynamic
with him as collaborative as some of the
other films you're known
such as with Linklater and where you
really have a lot of say in the
scripting and that kind of thing I would
say there is something very
old-fashioned about my relationship with
Paul Paul is a world-class writer it's
it's different than working but
certainly glitter is a wonderful writer
and I've written with him and I've read
lots of his scripts I just read a new
one it's absolutely amazing but his ego
his identity is rooted in directing
movies the script is a part of the
process that creates this finished thing
called a movie and Paul really is an
old-fashioned screenwriter
I mean it's meticulously built so it
doesn't need the same you know when when
Rick is working with you it's almost
like Mike Lee he's it was inviting you
to join his band he's asking you to come
up with a guitar solo for this section
he wants you to do it do you know and
he's picking you cuz you're light minded
and he's believing in you and that's a
really thrilling process with Paul I
really valued it because he gave me one
of the best roles I've ever read and he
asked me to give him a performance and
it wasn't a lot of talking and it wasn't
a lot of I mean his first question to me
when I met him I've read the script I
told him I loved that he met and he said
do you know what a recessive
performances and I said that I do it's
there's a certain kind of performance
that leans in and he's entertaining you
she's juggling she's dancing she's
amazing she's dynamic and there's
another kind that says no don't look at
me nothing's over here and it it's
asking you to step forward
and it's it's a really interesting
notion and that's about where our once
that direction was said I understood
what he wanted from me and it was really
one of the most challenging things but
it was it was old-fashioned acting yeah
you know I've never heard that term
before but I think that that idea
recessive performances exactly what I
was trying to say where you're not
beating the audience over the head with
it you're inviting the audience in one
of the things that made like for people
who love acting or love movies and stuff
one of the things that made Bergman so
amazing was that he he had these great
theater actors he's Swedish actors and
they they had done plays they really
knew each other really well and he could
really write for them and really create
these worlds and then they could take
their work and erase it when you watch
the great Birgit doesn't seem like
anyone's acting and it's so in but it's
just electric because of that so being
that you didn't have this super
back-and-forth relationship on coming up
with this character and this performance
and we don't have to talk spoilers if
you don't want to if you do we can put
up a warning the ending is a very
haunting moment in that film and I'm
curious for you as a performer because
Paul Schrader has said that it
intentionally can be read two ways as a
performer do you have to decide on one
of those being true to commit to that
performance in that moment that's a very
interesting question I my answer was yes
so I asked I really wanted to know what
it's happening so that I can play it and
Paul said that a great film
rings a bell great film starts as you
walk out of the theater and you don't
have to like it you'd have to agree with
it doesn't but it rings a bell you know
the one I often think about one for the
Cuckoo's Nest when when McMurphy's had a
lobotomy and everything's gone back to
normal and you see chief throw the sink
through this garden you know this locked
window and break the window and he runs
and he jumps into the woods and he's
running and you hear this drums is you
don't really know what it means it means
something but they don't tell you what
it means they're inviting you what do
you think yeah yeah you know and I
realized as Paul was talking to me that
he very clearly actually answers that
question it's people are so used to
everything being so spelled out that
they find it frustrating but early in
the movie I tell the young man when I'm
first counseling him that these guys
really depressed and I basically say
that wisdom is holding hope and despair
in your hand at the same time and I I
realize as he was not answering my
question that he had already answered it
that I was playing two things at once
I was playing hope and despair and that
I was gonna go around it was the longest
dim kiss of my life long kiss and and I
was had to do both yeah I like that
answer in that I think that line
resonated so much so of course it would
tie into the finale okay this is a your
filmmaker you're an artist you're writer
you're an actor when you look at the
film industry and how its evolving these
days with the rise of streaming services
or even something like movie path does
that make you more excited does it make
you nervous that things could be
overthrown in that way so cloak
everything's always overthrown yeah I
mean this that's life man one wave comes
in another way of leaves right it's
it's the way of nature and it's powerful
we live in an amazing moment technology
is exploding everything that I was
taught and that like the angle when I
was 18
finished in Dead Poets Society first
time being interviewed and stuff the
world looked very different from where I
was sitting than it does now what is a
movie what isn't a movie what those
words are are different there's still an
unbelievable value about watching a
movie with another group of people that
uh and it's and people said you know
what people said when the TV happened
that the theater would die guess what
the theater didn't die it's evolved and
changed but people still like to go see
a live rock show
there's nothing like seeing Neil Young
rip a guitar solo in some little dive
bar when you're one of 150 people that
actually saw it and you can't stream it
right it has a new value almost
literature's changing you know they're
getting the publishing companies are
getting really excited about how they do
their binding again because they want
you to have to what's the difference
between owning a book and reading it on
your phone well let's make it worthwhile
let's put it on good ink with good paper
and then you see public it's hard it's
changing unless saying it's it's gone
well it's never been easier to record an
album you know if you and I had an album
to do a weekend like garage bands pretty
damn good yeah really you know I mean
you can make stuff sound good well but
how do you get anybody to listen to it
making blaze I mean you know this would
have been unthinkable when I was a kid
to mount we went in there gonzo style we
came out with a movie that looks amazing
you know and we made it on a shoestring
budget we called it with love and duct
tape it's big it's it's there's nothing
that I wanted for the movie that I could
that would be better if I had more money
that's there's nothing you know that's
amazing but still hard to get it out
there because we're living in a world
where there is so there there's somebody
spending 120 million dollars on a movie
and they're got a 50 million dollar
advertising
budget so for me to say hey don't just
watch one kind of movie remember there's
movies about people - and there's movies
about feelings and hearts and sweat and
life and love right you know it's hard
but I'm not scared of that I mean I
think that life is changed and art
changes it always has changed I mean I
got to work with Sidney lament right at
the end of his life and he started in
live television well what if he was
scared of Marlon Brando he wasn't even
sure when change happened
he saw it when oh wow it's different now
I keep up with it you just you know it's
one of the things I you know when we
shot before the devil knows you're dead
you know it's one of the first I think
it was the first movie I shot all on
digital you know and it's funny it
already looks retro it's a different
kind it already has that kind of feel
that Dog Day Afternoon had people have I
yeah I agree any most digital films from
that era look very retro retro yes
people hadn't quite nailed the format
yet or it changed how we use it now so
one of the cool things about that though
is you talked about how hard it is for a
film like this to maybe find a bigger
audience
especially in this day and age something
like streaming services allow that to
happen at once it's on Netflix it's in
everybody's home and it's it's amazing
you know I mean I'm always pleasantly
surprised I did this movie born to be
blue about a jazz musician Chet Baker
and very few people saw that in the
theater and invariably if I gotta go
walk around somebody come up to me and
say they saw it last night
right you know and it's a great there's
a movie I did called predestination that
just kind of didn't really get released
it's a sign it's a good film and you can
find him people come up to me out of
nowhere say I watched it last night or
three weeks ago or and I loved that that
was one of your cool genre films and I
like that you do this occasionally I'm a
horror girl so I invariably was going to
take this conversation you hear it's
something that I find fascinating we
were just doing a podcast earlier we're
talking about the purge TV show
something you started on a micro budget
doing
favor for your friend jason blum has
become a massive franchise spawned a
prequel spawned a TV show what is that
like for you starting with something
that was made on such small means to see
it becomes dominating franchise
well it's awesome because first of all
lets me believe in my own literary taste
which is just because i read that script
and it's a pretty incendiary idea
it's a really exciting idea this idea
that in the future there'll be a world
where rich people don't care when poor
people and put violence on each other
right it's like it's like whoa the
movies really an intense the james
demonaco is a really smart person the
creator of that yeah and Jason and I
really believed in him and and I I love
watching different kinds of artwork you
know like the purge in a lot of ways an
old-fashioned drive-in movie you know
and there's a place for an old-fashioned
guy and you you you know and you can
hide truly if I said to you do you want
to see a very important film about race
relations in America uh not really you
know thanks a lot right if you say hey
you know you take the premise to get out
and say do you want to see that yes I do
yes please that sounds amazing and you
walk out having just been delivered a
thesis on race relations in America in a
way that was fun
funny wild and enjoyable right so
they're taking a subject matter that at
it's cursory glance it sounds
pretentious as hell but you make it fun
you know the howling when my first
movies Joe Dante in the howling is an
amazing movie about you know vietnam
vietnam war and guys coming back and
PTSD and you can see these things as
metaphors you know when I did sinister
scott derrickson challenged me to do a a
part about the evil of our own ego and
our own desire to be important in our
the ways that we put our career ahead of
our fan
and through the through the the monster
of ambition right that's really what is
that's what it is you saw so scary as
well okay and here's the thing is the
thing that's amazing and Scott said this
to me it's what I love about what I
learned from him Moses he said no we can
hide a metaphor in here but the metaphor
is useless if the movie ain't scary yeah
right it's a no you know we're gonna
roller coaster ride that does isn't fun
you can make the ride even more
interesting and have it have twists and
have it make it dynamic and make it
worth watching twice make it worth
watching three times but it's got to be
scary
yeah you know comedies got to be funny
doesn't matter if it's socially relevant
if it aint funny okay so you have really
I love talking about genre with you of
all these interesting perspectives on
things you don't strike me as somebody
who's particularly tapped into social
media are you okay are you aware that
your quotes on Logan caused a film
Twitter war sure did you saw that yeah
but you one of the things that's cool
about that is that's because for a long
time I thought about this a little bit
for a long time
comic books and people who cared about
comic books were ghettoized yeah and it
was made to feel small and now they run
the table and there's been this giants
which in my lifetime I mean like I am a
comic book geek I've seen all those who
the idea that I'm the one criticizing
them is a joke because I there's very
few things I enjoy more and so much I
teach my son that something about being
a geek is being real that's what it
means I'm gonna be real just like man I
love this and I don't think you should
be scared to say that you love something
that you hate something and that's the
job of movies and music and said it's
not to be liked it's to stir up
conversation and I was talking about a
much more nuanced point about the money
in America and what our obsession with
the accumulation of wealth is some of
the most talented mean Scott Derek since
dr. strange is amazing Chris Nolan's
Dark Knight James Mangold's Logan I
cited those because they're my favorites
and
took me as criticizing them what I was
trying to say is we need a community
that's making all kinds of movies so
that we're it's a part of it and it's I
think it pisses people off because they
don't want to go back to the ghetto or
comic books weren't taken seriously as
art and I agree with that
yeah and I think I mean there's a much
bigger conversation we had there about
nuance on social media and how always
kids lost but no that's specially one of
the things that drives you crazy
for me what's hard is you do a I'm doing
a press conference in Locarno Film
Festival with some Swiss Germans some
French you know people I'm in it's a
very different and it's a long
conversation and people take some
headline about and it's imbue it with a
meaning that wasn't present yeah so one
of the other fun things before I run out
of time with you that's been sort of
buzzing on social media about you right
now is this little back and forth love
you're sharing with Nicolas Cage oh yeah
and I just was personally curious again
is the horror girl have you seen Mandy
not yet but me I won't okay that looks
that looks like a return to form in a
big way
that's MacLaine at the IFC Center I
think when I get home it's great and
it's all that stuff you're saying about
how you love the way he performs and you
know sort of walks back on the
Stanislavski approach to naturalism a
little bit it's the perfect film for
that yeah I mean now there's no doubt
that Nic Cage is is rock and roll yeah
there you go whatever rock and roll is
that's Nic Cage yeah I like that well
said no I've been a big I we I've been a
fan of his and for there's nothing that
I've said recently that I haven't said a
hundred and thousand times at dinner
parties throughout you know it's
something I really believe in about him
that he's a true leader and a
revolutionary performer and one in a
million and I'm so excited that you know
this is the new whatever the next
chapter is and then people excited that
people are excited about Mandy cuz it
means I can't hi we gotta get you guys
back on screen together soon oh yeah
that's our I was going with that lord of
war man we had it if you haven't seen
Lord Award Andrew Niccol is a great hero
and directed Gattaca and he put Nik and
I together in one of my favorite endings
of any of the ending of Lord of war is
really good and Nick's amazing that's
another underrated one on your resume
thank you I think so too yeah that's a
good one if I'm allowed to you can you
can think good things I think you've
worked hard yeah yeah so um I mean I
know I'm just about out of time with you
so what do I want to focus on of course
I want to focus on the before trilogy
which is deep in my heart as well as
many people's hearts I believe you said
that that feels like a trilogy that
there is a conclusion how open are you
to that not being the case in 10 20
years there is all that needs to happen
is Julie to say I have an idea you know
a Rick to say hey guys I have an idea we
we worked really hard on those movies I
mean when we finished before midnight it
was about as tired as I've ever been in
my life there was something about taking
something that's really important to you
before sunrise it was such a risk to do
this before sunset
I loved before it was Julie and Rickon
are we it's such a good so scary to go
could we do it again then a third time
is like doubling like you doubled down
once got lucky and now you're gonna put
put the money on black again you know
and and that one is a much more
dangerous film the third one was scary
because you're not you're not making a
film about romantic projection you're
you're spinning the whole thing into
another dialogue about romance about
romantic reality and it was so hard to
write and perform and think about and
it's um I love that movie so I love all
three of them but so to revisit it we
would need an idea that was beyond you
don't want to cash in on those movies
you don't want to pour water and they
bit you know I mean it's too sacred
enough there is something to me there's
something about the way the first the
first movie starts where you're watching
an older couple in their 40s fight on a
train and the camera pulls back
you see a younger couple watching them
and then you know whatever
twenty-something years later we are that
great do you know and there's something
about that symmetry that feels good to
me and it feels like a complete artistic
experience that doesn't mean that we
couldn't start again in some new way but
it would need it would need all three of
us to be excited it must be something
you get asked about a lot because I I
know how much those movies mean to me
and that I'm not alone in that
yeah I my bunch is that Rick and Julie
and I are gonna work together Jesse and
Celine will appear and I just don't know
how and what and way right well we were
joking in the chat I guess kind of
joking come true and sad you should just
make a more with you guys and it'll be
the saddest we've we have talked about
the it's perfect it's perfect it's
perfect we only trouble is in it like
most of our fanbase will you know be not
in the movie going alive you know okay
all right well I gotta wrap up with you
thank you so much you're a lovely person
to talk to it were you oh thank you
be sure to check out blaze guys and be
sure to check out first reformed and
keep an eye on this guy during award
season